[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up prof
good day walter
good day today i'm chilling and i have
a what the english call it jersey
i want to keep the cold out i'll brace
myself and try and get through this
with just my shirt today
will you open up for us with a prayer
please absolutely
heavenly father
we are dealing with very serious issues
and we need heavenly enlightenment
and i pray that you will guide our
thoughts
and help us
to find
the truth
in the maze of lies that exist in the
world in jesus name amen amen
in the previous episode you mentioned
that we will
be going into discussions about the king
of the north
and city get out of the cities etc but
there's also some other interesting
things that you've mentioned that you
would like to talk about how did these
ideas come to you and maybe you can give
us an introduction of what we're going
to be
talking about in the next lecture also
well it's going to be
more than one yes because this is quite
a big topic
and i see you've curtailed my movement
here
because i was swinging around
on this chair yeah we're looking like
merry-go-round
kids playing on the merry-go-round going
backwards and forwards and yeah so i see
my movement has been restricted but okay
i hope my
the talking has not been restricted
we've titled it conspiracy conspiracy
theories with a big question mark
now
this is always a hot topic right
so i'm wondering whether some
what do they say in the movies if
certain people are not to watch or
certain eight clashes parental guidance
parental guidance or something like that
well perhaps uh you know very sensitive
people
or people that cannot think outside of
the box should rather tune out yes
because they could become
confused or maybe upset and maybe start
writing articles and things like that so
let's uh that's a disclaimer that you've
changed it's just a disclaimer i guess
it's better not to watch
so all sensitive people
please
take it with uh
yes for what it's worth for what it's
worth yes
okay so
well get us into
how you got the i
what
is the method behind all of this how how
does it get together
there are so many links
there are so many things that happen in
the world that seem to be disjointed
something happening over here something
happening over there
and
is it now truth or is it a conspiracy
theory
how does it fit into the pattern now
we've already in the past said we apply
a filter right
and that filter is the word of god
given through the bible
and through his prophets
so how do we how do we
connect the dots
and where are we going
i believe and i think you believe that
the time is short we are living in the
last days and
we are
slowly reaching a climax
and we know from scripture that the
climax will not be a pretty sight please
if you take
for example just the destruction of
jerusalem
which serves as a type
for the destruction of the world
then we have to know that
issues are very very serious
now
i have to ask myself the question what
were conditions like
in the antediluvian world
that god would come to the
the realization
that
this whole structure
has to be destroyed yes
why would god get to the point where he
can destroy
virtually all of humanity
it must be pretty serious right correct
now is he a tyrant
is he a monster that wants to
enforce his will my way or the highway
or what is what is the real issue
now we know what the character of god is
because we've seen it in the bible right
jesus portrays the character of god to
us and
when i when i study the bible and i see
the contrast
between the rigid mode of the the
scribes and the pharisees
and the mode of
of activity and thinking of jesus
then the choice is clear
they had so many restrictions so many
rules so
they were control freaks to the power of
ten yes
and jesus ignored
their directives
that were contrary to the word of god
but perfectly suited to control and
power mongering
and if i look at the two and i i look at
my own spirit
how i even as a child used to rebel
against this authoritarian mode of
thinking
then
i'm attracted
to one side rather than the other side
and
not that god doesn't have rules he does
have rules
but
his his whole methodology is to
show you why his rules are absolutely
logical
and why they are essential
he never says to you
perennial cadaver be like a corpse and
obey me
he says
come let us reason together
and we have the these conflicting modes
of control yes
the one mode of control that god exerts
is by appealing to your intellect
and appealing to your heart and bringing
the intellect and the heart together
into harmony with his will
which is perfect once you have studied
it and the other one is a is a coercion
you will do it my way
or the highway
and now when we look at conspiracy
theories
we see that many many things are decided
behind the scenes
yes
just go to the bible
jesus says i have done nothing in secret
if you want to know what i stand for ask
these
i said it publicly nothing is secret
so anything that is secret
is
conspiratorial if you could take in
contrast the way the pharisees decided
about his
putting him to death everything was done
in secret yes there's a whole conspiracy
theory going just on there
his trial everything now ask yourself a
question
when you go through history
and you look at the modus operandi of
satan
he will try and control you try and make
you do it his way
force you
uh would he coerce yes absolutely if you
didn't comply would it
be inquisitorial yes
yes
and if you then still didn't comply
would he burn you at the stake yes
absolutely
so this is his mindset
and this is the mindset that you find
in the world out there and when you come
across that mindset you know who's
behind that mindset
any form of controlling the world
any form of coercion
is not from god
god always appeals to your
intellect and to your conscience
and so when we're going to discuss these
conspiracy theories
we
will see what the real agenda is
and we will also have to look at what
god's response is going to be
so does satan want the whole of humanity
in his camp yes
will there be a little mordekai in the
gate that irritates
him yes will he try eventually to
obliterate that yes any mode of thinking
i mean we discussed that what the
hierarchy says of the roman catholic
church
has to be accepted and you have to give
up your freedom of choice we read the
jesuit documents you have to give up
your freedom of choice and you have to
accept it that way because it's their
way or the highway right so that's
definitely not from god no it's
definitely that's what i just wanted to
say
god always fights for your freedom of
choice
does the bible tell us
that
this conflict will escalate towards the
end
yes
will there be an attempt at obliterating
those that don't go along with the
agenda
and
where do you expect the greatest
opposition
in countries that have become used to
thinking in the robotic fashion of their
leaders
i mean i'm always surprised when i look
at the
people that are virtually brainwashed
when you look at for example military
exercises i mean these authoritarian
regimes love to display their military i
mean they are just so spot on
and they they all
exactly the same and yes when this one
says
a then they shout a and there's no mind
of their own anymore it's
unbelievable
and this is the way in which he's
heading
and we have a time frame
because we are heading towards the
climax of the ages and we are supposed
to watch the signs
so we're going to look at some very
strange web pages which might be
disturbing to some people
but we have to look at how they fit into
the prophetic scenario
now
some of these
might seem to come from
conspiracy pages but some of them are
actually official government pages
and very high official
organizations
that basically run the world
and we will be surprised that uh reality
is more stunning than fiction
and uh that's when it gets scary that's
ridiculous so shall we jump into it
let's get into it
we did give a disclaimer
i think maybe i can also add an ad on
the disclaimer
some people might think we're
fear-mongering yes but we're actually
trying to mix
to get sense that people can also maybe
think about how things
link together how they link together
because if you're in the know of you
seeing these things
then you're not scared
you're only scared of the unknown
and this is another point does the bible
tell us that we are fighting a war
against spiritual forces
yes it does right
so will the occult world
sort of come into the scenario
definitely will uh communications with
demons perhaps be
part of the issue
definitely do world leaders actually
communicate with demons yes absolutely
we've shown videos in the past of
of communications between the highest
politicians and the so-called deceased
which are demons because they the
deceased know nothing right right
so
there are many issues that will come in
here which to some people are whoa this
this this can't be real
when i just think back let's say roger
mono and journey into the supernatural
to many people that is an unreal world
but i actually was involved in that
world and it's not unreal
i actually communicated in my
past experience with demons directly
directly
i know what it is like and someone who's
grown up in in a little bubble protected
from all of these things would think oh
this is not part of reality this is
reality yes when you are in a session
where you're actually communicating with
demons that is a reality and it cannot
be cannot be denied so let's jump
right into it
there's a web page
and
it's a very interesting web page
it is deagle.com
now it's not a government web page
but it is a real intelligence
organization for the united states
government and it makes some very
strange predictions
it was actually used in the wikileaks
issue and governments have used it in
the past to
actually
you know
determine some of the issues that
surround
developments in the world now here's a
web page that is not deagle
it's a steemit.com
and they're asking the question here
what is this global depopulation by
2025.
interesting year
now we're not setting a date no we're
just quoting a web page
and we will go to deagle and see what
they actually have to say here's a
a blog page al gore blog
which talks about these issues and of
course they are linking depopulation now
with the
bill gates plan
and they have you know very interesting
things here that are quite sensational
the depopulation agenda bill gates plans
to kill you that's of course
ridiculous one man
is not behind
a huge plan like this and if there is a
plan like that if it exists at all
then there must be other powers behind
it right correct he won't be alone
so they also quote diego
and says makes this
mysterious changes to the 2025
population forecast
they continue and they talk about the
development of a universal vaccine and
that this is going to be one of the
means to bring about this depopulation
but
you know if something is so in your face
then that's what people want you to
believe
but behind it there might be a deeper
issue and we want to
study the deeper issue
the devil also wants to prepare the
world for what is coming yes is the
devil a student of scripture yes
and he will appear as an angel of light
so that doesn't mean he's coming as a
demon okay so if he has a good idea
of where we are in the stream of time
and if he knows
what the boundaries are
where god will not allow
uh mankind to go any further i mean
there is such a boundary it existed in
the flood yes and it existed at sodom
and it
existed at gemara right
there's a point and there's also a point
where nations may not exceed a certain
bound
then they will be removed
so he knows the agenda
and knowing the agenda perhaps he even
has a much better idea of the time frame
than we have
so what if he can be predictive
exactly that would be interesting yes
okay
so here this webpage tells us
what deagle sources are and they believe
that these are the deep state sources of
course
this comes from deagle itself sources
u.s department of defense
department of the state the cia world
bank european union
and
united states coast guard department of
defense government air force army marine
corps navy
those are the sources that they use
and
it's very interesting so this man claims
that these are deep state sources so
let's go to those web pages
and just see what they have to say
deagle.com he has a partial list of
known deagle partners and clients
according to their own website
national security agency
north atlantic treaty organization
organizations for economic cooperation
and development
osce russian defense procurement agency
stratfor the world bank you know it's
pretty impressive right
yes a pretty impressive list and it's
interesting that this web page doesn't
have an about us section yeah they don't
tell you it's not easy to see
yeah who are the but wikileaks was
involved in it governments have used it
and not many people know about it but
it's out there right
uh
fascinating
uh this comes directly from their own
web page and they are going to explain
here why they have this massive
prediction of a population reduction
well look at that at it in a moment
and it's a long story
and they're saying well
it's not necessarily war
it could just be migration
it could be changes in the economy
and of course the epidemics
that could lead to
things like this so let's just read some
of the things that they say here where
why they have these predictions there
have been many questions about the
country's forecast especially the ones
focusing
on the united states of america they
won't be answered one by one
but below you can find some explanation
thoughts and reflections we are going to
keep this as short as possible
the majority of the economic and
demographic data used in the making of
the forecast is widely available by
institutions such as the
cia imf united nation usg etc so they
say that themselves
so here in this first paragraph
they say that pandemics will play a
major role in the reduction of the
populations
and then
the collapse of the western financial
system will wipe out the standard of
living of its population
while ending posi schemes such as the
stock exchange and the pension funds
the population will be hit so badly by a
full array of bubble and posi schemes
that the migration engine will start to
work in reverse accelerating itself due
to
ripple effects thus leading to the
demise of the states
so they're predicting
virtually
a wipeout right people
migrating out of the united states again
okay but the time frame is so
fascinating
so sorry to disappoint many of you with
our forecast it is getting worse and
worse every year since the beginning of
the pre-crisis in 2007
and
they're not going to say anything else
about it
now yeah here is a very interesting
sentence it says the figure itself is
not important what is relevant is the
fact that the scenario can evolve beyond
the initial conditions
from a 50 percent death toll to more
than 90 percent
that's interesting wiping out 90
by the way
no pandemic or nuclear war is included
in the forecast
they're talking about a pandemic here
yeah
but in this forecast in this case no
pandemic
or nuclear war is in the forecast
so what will wipe out those populations
i don't know
now this is where it gets interesting
this is where we have to put on our
thinking camps
now let's take a country like india for
example
this is very interesting
they have here india what the currency
is and the year of assessment of their
population in this
table here is 2017
the population was 1.3 billion
and then it tells you
what its gross domestic product is
and all of these issues
now it's interesting the gross domestic
product was 2.4 trillion yes
then they have a forecast for 2025.
the population they say is going to
increase
it's a green arrow
and it's still going to be 1.3 billion
but the numbers will have increased so
obviously
issues like pandemics
or nuclear war didn't affect them and
migration
migration nothing
the gross domestic product is going to
be 5.1 trillion
when it was before 2.4 trillion in other
words it's going to more than double
that's astounding
and that's from 2017 to 2025.
we don't see anything like that
at the moment
nothing like it
now that's very interesting all right
but
it gets fascinating when we get to the
others let's take germany
that's a western country yes
it's a christian country right correct
and the previous one was not a christian
country
the year
2017 the population 81 million
these are just facts
then
the gross domestic product
3.7 trillion
at the moment that is more than what
india's was right
then
it goes down and it tells you the
forecast for
2025 and the arrow is red the population
is going to drop to 28 million excuse me
this is the forecast
from 81 million
to 28 million
now if they don't include ben
demix and nuclear wars in this then
what's going to happen to germany
why would they say that
why would there be virtually an 80
reduction in population are they all
going to emigrate
are they all going to become russians
are they going to emigrate to north
america
no because they're going to go down as
well maybe to north africa
i don't know
but it's fascinating that they will have
a total population
collapse
or destruction
according to their estimate
and their gross domestic product will
drop down to 621
billion
from
a mighty 3.7 trillion
in other words their total economy is
going to be destroyed
this sounds like national run yeah have
you heard that word before yes
i wonder who used the word national rune
a prophet
now
this is very serious
and uh
people will say conspiracy theory
this is not a conspiracy theory this is
a a statistical forecast from deagle for
whatever reason they don't really say
right
look at italy
again the population in 2017 62 million
they're going to experience a drop to 44
million not as bad as germany no
but it's still a considerable
calamity
if uh
20 million people disappear from your
population yes that that is a horrendous
disaster
definitely and their gross domestic
product is going to drop down
from 1.9 trillion to 1.3 trillion so
they're not as badly hit as germany
according to this
why could this be
doesn't that make you think yeah you're
involved
it's interesting you have to start
thinking
let's go to another non-christian
country
japan
gross domestic product 4.9 trillion
population 126 million
let's drop down to the forecast
population 103 million so they're going
to you lose 23 million people in their
population
that's a lot that's a lot of people yes
that's a lot of people 23 million people
gone within the next five years
according to them yeah
not because of war
not taken into account
and then you go down to the gross
domestic product which will drop from
4.9 trillion to 3.1 trillion so it's not
as bad as germany which is totally
obliterated
according to their statistics
russia
in 2017 the population 142 million
the forecast for 2025 142 million
no reduction in population
nothing
what do these people know
that we don't
i know
or maybe
do not yes
okay
what about gross domestic product it was
1.6 trillion in 2017
and it's going to go up to 4.3 trillion
that's going to triple at least
this is astounding
spain
a catholic country in europe
and uh
what do we have here 49 million people
in the country
2017 gross domestic product 1.3
trillion population reduction down to
million
that's slightly almost half the
population is going to be wiped out
according to this within the next five
years for whatever reason
and the gross domestic product will also
drop
substantially
to
553 billion whereas at the moment it's
1.3 trillion
israel
because there are people that say
the zionists are behind this it's a
zionist plot to wipe out the population
so i included israel just for interest
as to what is happening there
8.3 million is the population in
2017 or was the population
and it is going to drop to 4 million so
they're going to lose more than half
their population
that's quite fascinating
their gross domestic product is going to
drop substantially from 348 billion to
70 billion
so israel is going to be very hard hit
france what's going to happen to you
population 67 million in 2017
down to 39 million
it's also
significant
that's very significant
now
always bear in mind india
and russia
no population drop
now let's go to canada
population 36 million
gross domestic product to 1.6 trillion
they're forecast for 2025 26 million
they're going to lose 10 million people
that's a third of their population gone
gone
that's incredible
this is just the forecast of course
now what do they
know that
the world apparently does not know and
if they know
what is their source yes where does this
all come from where does this come from
so gross domestic product will also
drop
south africa just for interest sake
55 million the population will drop to
46 million so
it's a 9 million
drop in population
which is substantial i mean if we had to
say in the next
five years
10 million people are going to die
that's quite shocking and that must also
then include births and deaths so
with all of that it still goes down 9
million but when you say to germany 50
million of your population are going to
die
out of your 80 something million
that is
that's shocking beyond measure
now let's look at the poor united states
of america
population 327 million in
2017 they predict it's going to drop to
100 million
now that's
that's
what's going to happen to 227 million
people
michael two-thirds of the population
gone are they all going to move to
mexico
i don't know this is where that makes no
sense what they're trying to tell you
but are they going to move to canada
no because canada is also it's also got
a drone so they're definitely not moving
anywhere
all right
and it's not a pandemic and it's not a
wall according to them
and the gross domestic product is going
to drop down to 2.4 trillion
from a mighty
19 trillion they're going to be a
third world country yes
in the next
five years well it's four years now yeah
because this one's nearly gone
basically can you see it
happening
now let's look at the poor united
kingdom
this is unbelievable population
currently 66 million or it was in 2017
it's going to drop to 15 million
51 million people of their population
are predicted to be gone
they're not moving to europe nope
because europe is going down
and in russia
the population basically stood at the
same this is this is almost the worst of
them this is horrendous
this is horrendous
what do these people know
well here's just a
broader summary
let's have a look at china for example
the population in 2017 was 1.38
billion
and they predict the drop to 1.358
billion which is not a great drop
compared to that huge number
their gross domestic product is going to
increase from 11.94
trillion to
16.967 so they will be the mightiest
nation in terms of gross domestic
product and population
in the next four years
brazil is going to have an increase of 3
million so
the americans certainly didn't migrate
those 250 million people didn't migrate
to south america right not according to
this
mexico
their population is going to stay
exactly the same
virtually it's going to have a slight
increase
so they didn't go to mexico either no
and they didn't go to canada no
so the only other conclusion must be
that they no longer exist
now if i were to tell you
that in the next four years
virtually the entire population of the
united states except for a handful will
be obliterated
would that shock you of course
and if i told you that virtually
eighty percent of the population of
germany will be obliterated with that
shock you yes
would you book your airplane ticket to
go there no
no
it's shocking
definitely not
okay let's just take a step back
people will accuse us now of fear i'm
wondering
we weren't fear-mongering we were
reading statistics right
what could lead to such a demise but i
have another question
it seems to be the christian countries
that are being hardest hit yes
europe
england in particular germany yes
the others as well italy not as bad as
as germany france
very bad spain very bad but not as bad
as germany and not nearly as bad as the
united kingdom
canada has a huge reduction the united
states is virtually wiped out right
yes
that's what the scenario is
now there are many conspiracy theories
out there as to what the cause is going
to be
asteroids
planet x
[Music]
collisions
but that doesn't explain the selective
destruction
in particularly christian countries if
it were to come about
in the first place
now
we have these statements which claim
that national apostasy will lead to
national
run
uh the bible says
that the earth will wear out like in the
garment and its inhabitants will die
like flies
so there is coming a massive destruction
now
if you have a lot of light
are you not responsible for that light
and if you reject that light
then national ruin is the consequence
we will look at some of these issues
alan white has a statement in education
education
that every kingdom or has had
the opportunity to do god's will
and eventually like for instance babylon
yes then the media persians all these
great kingdoms
and they didn't live up to what they
should
and eventually they were taken away
so maybe history can repeat itself
for another nation other nations that
had this great light well we will see we
will try and put this all together it's
a very scary thing to do
now ronald reagan at some stage said
that
the world would surely unite if it
if there was an alien
invasion yeah his first speech was very
speculative but it became more and more
forceful as he went along right yes now
i also find it interesting that ronald
reagan was very much into the occult
world
he wouldn't make a move politically
without consulting the astrologers
and there were communications
that his wife had
with entities and
political people like
both the clintons had communication with
spirit entities etc
i couldn't help but one
point in my discussions with privately
with
general secretary gorbachev
when you stop to think that we're all
god's children wherever we may live in
the world
i couldn't help but say to him just
think how easy his task and mine might
be in these meetings that we held
if suddenly there was a threat to this
world
from some other species
from another planet
outside in the universe
we'd forget all the local differences
that we have between our countries and
we would find out once and for all that
we really are
all
human beings here on this earth together
well
i don't suppose we can wait for some
alien race to come down and threaten us
but i think that between us we can bring
about
that realization
thank you all god bless you all
does the bible speak of an
outside intervention coming
the coming of jesus
the coming of jesus now
the forces of evil
in the spiritual realm
did they engage in a war
against this outside force at some prior
occasion yes yes
the bible tells us there was a war in
heaven right
and uh the spirit of prophecy tells us
that that was as much a physical war as
any other war it was a real war
do you think he could be preparing for
another war
definitely would he want all the forces
on his side to face this great threat
the bible says he knows his time wax is
short
now some of the politicians deny
that there are
alien forces or try to allay fears but
their their own institutions don't right
so let's have a look at some of these
these are very interesting
the federal government is being
increasingly open about its decades-long
investigation of ufos they have spent
millions of dollars and officials admit
now they've seen many things they don't
understand we decided to ask the
president about it
it was his semi-cryptic answer watch
you gave an interview the day in which
you said you've been briefed on
unidentified flying objects
are they are they real
uh well i don't want to really get into
it too much but personally i tend to
doubt it uh i mean you have people that
swear by it right and pilots have come
in and they said and these are pilots
that are
not pilots that are
into that particular world but we have
had people saying that they've seen
things
i'm not a believer but you know i guess
anything's possible we spoke to a
government official recently who said
the us government had wreckage from a
ufo in a facility on an air force base
are you familiar i haven't heard that no
i haven't heard that
it has not been within government has
not been a big thing but i've seen it
i've seen it on your show but i've seen
it
i don't assume it's correct but you know
i have an open mind tucker i know you do
mr president thank you for nowadays you
can believe anything right
well much of the media have mocked the
existence of unidentified flying objects
the u.s pentagon has been studying this
subject for quite a long time and
apparently will soon release some of its
findings which remain classified
according to a new report in the new
york times the u.s government may have
physical evidence of and we're quoting
off-world vehicles not made on this
earth
the government has also released footage
of ufo sightings including a 2004
encounter recorded from an advanced navy
fighter jet
this whole issue of uh out of this world
vehicles that have been found by the way
they were found in archaeological digs
here
now you know we have this notion that
man has was always primitive and we have
reached the pinnacle of
culture and science at the moment and we
are the brilliant ones
the bible talks of a far
more brilliant race than we were namely
the antediluvian world
and even the poster luvian world
noah and his sons
they were brilliant yes huge in stature
great longevity
and there have been some very strange
finds and there are interesting studies
out there on hidden archaeology and
technology that has been found that is
amazing that we do not understand even
there have been talks of
military discoveries
it's interesting that adolf hitler
sent a huge archaeological team to egypt
during the war because he wanted to find
some of these secrets right and it was
very important for him to procure
those secrets
now
we still to this day don't know what
happened to any of those secrets if and
should they have been discovered we are
heavily into conspiracy theories
now i used to be involved in occultism
i used to practice out-of-body
experiences this is part of my testimony
my father-in-law was one who brought out
the magazine inner space for the new age
movement
he
he was
very fascinated by all of these things
and we were once sitting in a in a
restaurant
in
the cape
overlooking the ocean
and suddenly
two ufos appears appeared over the ocean
now this restaurant had huge glass
windows and everybody saw it
and we went and stood at the window and
these two objects were
playing as it were flying backwards and
forwards
up and down
and i saw it with my own eyes my wife
was there as well my father-in-law was
there and the other people in the
restaurant of course don't know who they
were
and we watched this for a while
and then two mirage jets were scrambled
by the south african defence force and
they rushed towards these flying objects
and these flying objects were playing
the four with them
and then they would they would come and
they would just go
they were much higher than the others
and the mirage would have to make a long
turn and come back and then they were
over there and then they were over there
eventually they gave up and they left
and the next moment those things took
off now
real
well i saw them so that was pretty real
it wasn't an illusion because others saw
them as well
it's interesting that
the ufo society people
they have many tales of communicating
with the beings inside of these and i
also find it interesting that whenever
there was contact of that kind of nature
there were certain spiritual
manifestations yes
for example people started speaking in
tongues
when they came into contact with them
this is now according to some of these
witnesses
and in some of my previous lectures i
spoke about these issues
now
they also wore emblems like the serpent
with wings now these are all biblical
symbols
so
my current understanding
and those that have made the transition
from the occult world
to being bible believers many of them
are of the same understanding that we
are dealing with outside forces demonic
forces yes
these are demonic manifestations
and we had ufo experiences on the farm
where i was living
and these were in the form of bright
lights just shooting left and right and
coming over your house and doing this
and leaving burn marks in the field
just as i've been reported i saw these
things with my own eyes when i was
deeply involved in the occult world
now of course i know what the source is
and it is demanding
now if people claim that they have had
communications
with these beings is it possible
that
forces high up in the
in the government could have
communications with these people we're
in indeed conspiracy theories now so we
better be careful
but
it's a possibility i mean there are
literally hundreds of books written
about this kind of thing
and you read them and you know what is
truth and what is fiction it's very hard
to tell but by my own experience
i know these things are real
and that they are
spiritual
manifestations
and
obviously these beings
must have technologies available to them
does god have technologies available to
him yes yes he can muster any force that
he wants
would they try to muster those forces
those same ones
absolutely definitely
now
let us continue
read even in in very reputable uh
sources like deutsche
baveria huge crop circle science
attracts hundreds of onlookers
and the augsburg alga miner it's a
newspaper reports that these crop
circles have been forming
in the region around the amazing for
years and it's noteworthy
that there is an important earth station
for communications satellites in the
region etc etc so you know these things
are
well known
now the georgia guidestones
were placed there by mysterious
individuals
and they of course had
uh
an acronym yeah the guy that went to
the people to make these
stones for them yes these initials were
interesting see christians and then at
the georgia guidestones it has
the events that they foretell
and rc christian
then also has had placed there the
writing
age of
reason
now we're going to get to revelation
chapter 11 in this discussion because we
have to bring all of this stuff to the
bible yes
and it's scary
but it's fascinating that's it
and then we have to link it to our
filter the bible and the spirit of
prophecy and we have to sift and see
where we are and what all these things
mean
now uh
the age of reason
is something that has been coming for
the while it actually started
in a in a political way
in the time of the french revolution yes
now what does this reason bring about
well the first one was of course to
maintain humanity
at 500 million that's half a billion
people
that means that more
that almost the world population must be
obliterated from the seven point
something to eight billion we must go
down to half a billion so where are all
these people going to go
guide reproduction wisely
this is on the georgia guidestones
so guide reproduction who's going to
take control of reproduction the
government the government's going to
take control of reproduction
now when i was in the occult world
my father-in-law who was as i said
one of the first ones to bring in the
new age movement
and he also introduced me of course to
very high people in that
realm like the channels of africa i mean
i spoke to them face to face it's part
of my testimonies
this becomes very very interesting
to
lower the population
and to guide reproduction wisely and he
was writing a book i don't think he
finished it before his death
and the book's name was meritania
now it was based on a system of merit
mere tamiya you could only reproduce
if you fulfill certain conditions okay
so if you were involved in anything like
voting or something you would have to
have certain number of merit points okay
yeah in order to do that if you wanted
to move around freely you had to have
certain merit points if you wanted to be
able to reproduce then something had to
be unlocked or technology would have to
take over in order to make you reproduce
now this is years ago yeah
and i was steeped in this kind of
thinking
now if you look at chinese technology
today which is actually universal
technology do they have a point system
yes
absolutely they have a point system
if you want to be able to travel you
have to have certain number of points
right if you want to do this you must
with the coronavirus they've got now the
app you've got absolutely you have to
scan your
qr code and then if you're green you can
go in the shop or whatever
so let's look at this
very in-your-face so-called conspiracy
theory
age of reason
now
the jesuits
they are into reasons
remember we discussed richard m goula
reason informed by faith and i still
said no no no it should be the other way
around right they are the ones that say
reason is the highest standard that's
the jesuit thinking
reason we're going into an age of reason
the one who put it there is r c
christian roman catholic christian what
are the jesuits
roman catholic christians aha the
society of jesus so they want an age of
reason and then they want to unite
humanity with a living new language the
bible says babylon spoke one language
they want to go back to babylon the
bible calls them babylon and we have to
make sure that we come out of babylon
have nothing to do with the system is
it's going to get very hard we are just
doing an introduction here we're going
to go quite deeply into this
then you have to rule passion
you have to rule faith
you have to
could you do that with an app
yes
could you do that with
ai yes
is it possible to control the genes that
produce faith centers
all very interesting tradition you have
to rule and all things with tempered
reason
now who are the ones who are going to do
the reasoning
in order to control those that don't
want to be
reasonable
according to them so they're going to be
the control freaks and you're going to
be the controlled one
protect people and nations with fair
laws and just courts
that's fascinating i don't know whether
they'll succeed
let all nations rule internally
resolving external disputes in a world
court so they want a world government
avoid petty laws and useless officials
balance personal rights and social
duties it seems like social justice is
involved here prize truth
beauty love seek harmony with the
infinite but that infinite is definitely
not god not the god of the bible no
didn't he say be fruitful and multiply
yes these people say the opposite right
be not a cancer on the earth leave room
for nature it sounds like
climate change climate change
leave room for nature they say it twice
avoid petty laws and useless officials
doesn't that also maybe
pull in to defund the police
oh yes let's get rid of the police as
well
i will put a link in on a documentary
that uh
that was made on the georgia guidestones
very good it's dark clouds over
that would alberta
nice that'll be very nice
here is a national geographic article
new object beyond pluto hints at
mysterious planet x
the solar system's retinue of known
faraway worlds has gained another member
a small icy body that takes 40 000 years
to plod once around the sun
and then there are web pages which say
that
planet x in some way or other
will
destroy the united states virtually
and that they're claiming that the
united states will be divided into two
there will be a major
sea where the mississippi is now joining
up to the great lakes florida
and both coastlines will totally
disappear that means all the big cities
on the coast will be gone
that's what they're saying yeah and
there's no evidence for such a planet x
now there's also been a few prophets can
we put it like that
that predicted a few things
on this planet x there's also a few
other names for it
now i'm wondering if there's no truth to
this
where do we find truth
on the georgia guide stones definitely
not right
so the only place i can find truth is in
the bible correct thy word is truth
now the bible says
what is going to happen to this world
and the bible says what is going to
happen
to
the christian world when it reaches
across the gulf
to take the hand of rome
and enact
this system of reason over and above
god's government
and in act traditional laws over god's
law right correct
and once that decision has been made and
once persecution in regard to that
commences
god will intervene
and we read
in matthew 24 and in the spirit of
prophecy that calamities will increase
that there will be calamities and
destruction of cities
does it say that yes and that the
calamities and the destruction will
bring people to say let's implement
laws
that are religious nato sunday law
being particularly prominent yes
does the devil know something that he
wants to attribute to nature and to a
so-called planet x
or to
other so-called
forces
now they have also been movies
now hollywood
well i don't actually call it hollywood
i call it jesus theater
so that people can get the idea
as to exactly
what they are trying to do and they're
always trying to prepare people for what
is coming
sensitizing you most of the time like
for instance the pandemic yeah how many
movies were there of a pandemic so
once it comes okay all right the
pandemic is now here
let me quote the occult world directly
now
alice a bailey
hierarchy will manifest itself
now this is interesting now alisa bailey
is basically
the prophet test for the united nations
yes
she
is
the one that followed blavatsky
now when i was still involved in all of
these things
i was pertinently told by one of the
highest channels in the world
that if you are a student of blavatsky
then you have arrived
yes this is a personal experience
and
alice a
of course temple of understanding and
all of these things in the united
nations they they are schooled the whole
education system
is schooled on alice a bailey let's have
a look at this quote
it comes from a book the externalization
of the hierarchy we always explain who
the hierarchy is
the hierarchy of those spiritual
master entities that run the world from
behind the scenes
this is a reality in the thinking of the
united nations right correct
otherwise they wouldn't have it as an
official organization affiliated to the
united nations yes
and
this hierarchy
if you know your bible is of course a
demonic hierarchy these are demons
communicating with humanity yes this is
what it is
now we can look at the publisher it was
written in 1957 and it's lucius trust
which originally was lucifer publishing
company
but the name was too much in the face so
they changed it to lucis trust same
thing
she writes
thus a great and new movement is
proceeding and a tremendously increased
interplay and interaction is taking
place interaction with whom yes
this will go on until
that's stunning
ad 2025
during the years intervening between now
and then very great changes will be seen
taking place when was this written
written
1950 1957
this is interesting
very great changes will be seen taking
place
and at the great general assembly of the
hierarchy what you're talking about here
a meeting of the demonic forces a
meeting of the demonic forces
held as usual every century
in
2025 the date in all probability will be
set for the first stage of the
externalization of the hierarchy
what does that mean
where they will present themselves to
humanity so that you can see them face
to face does that sound like satan
masquerading as an angel of light saying
i am the christ i have come back yes
i've changed the laws didn't we deal
with that in the spirit of prophecy that
he will say i have changed the laws so
must have been an attempt to
keep sunday by that stage is he
reinforcing it yes were there calamities
that led people to believe these things
we're just putting it into a biblical
scenario
which countries
would be hardest hit
those that had the light protestant
countries and rejected it
national apostasy will be followed by
national rune
interesting
the date in all probability will be set
for the first stage of the
externalization of the hierarchy
the present cycle from now until that
date is she making that date prominent
yes
what was the date in diego 2025 what was
the date in that movie clip
2025 uh who runs
hollywood
jesuits jesuit theater
fascinating
the present cycle from now until that
date is called technically the stage of
the forerunner
forerunner to whom
satan
it is preparatory in nature
testing in its methods are we being
tested right now as to how far we can be
pushed yes how far they can put the
control on us
and intended to be revelatory in its
techniques and results
you can see therefore
that
chohans masters initiates world
disciples disciples and aspirants
affiliated with the hierarch excuse me
according to the statement from
alice a bailey
an official
part of the ruling powers of this world
are the
people in the world
involved in this issue and people in
the governments
talking to these entities yes
so there's communication between the
demonic world
uh could these demons be saying this
coming an intervention we must prepare
for it get your space wars ready
i mean we're really talking conspiracy
as well right
so i hope that all the sensitive people
have tuned out
at this stop
tinfoil ads yes
you can therefore see the
show hands the masters the initiates
so where would you find initiates in
secret societies
what do they call
a person who leads let's say a masonic
lodge a master a grand master a grand
master even a worshipful master not just
the word worshipful master
jesus says call no one
master
and you shall worship the lord thy god
and him alone and here this man is
called worshipful master shouldn't that
ring a bell in every mind out there that
is associated with secret societies
shouldn't they run for their lives
shouldn't they flee from them
knowing that this is a demonic
organization if they even dare to use
terminology like that
but they don't see it
initiates world disciples disciples and
aspirants affiliated with the hierarchy
affiliated
that means joined together with demonic
forces sitting at one table
are all at this time passing through a
cycle of great activity
she continues today human beings as a
whole are so loudly invocative that the
entire trend of the life of the
hierarchy and its plans to date have
been subject to change
i'm glad god interferes every now and
then
to postponement as far as certain
interior and purely hierarchical
determinations are concerned
and to a hastening of certain plans
which were slated if i may use such a
word
to take place several centuries later
than this but which owing to the
unexpected preparedness of humanity can
take place not prematurely really but
securely in the fullness of time
this is amazing of course this is
eyewash yeah satan knows the time frame
exactly
but he's talking
to his people as though you know this is
going to go on forever but because you
are so beautifully brilliant
i've listened to many
of these communications and the way he
speaks
and
in the new age movement the matreya my
dear ones my super intelligent ones my
this my that it's incredibly irritating
the terminology or fullness of time is
also
that i was just going to comment on i'm
glad you noticed that too the fullness
of time he knows the time frame
we've talked about time frames and we
certainly haven't made them long time
frames
and 2025
is well within
those time frames
now we're not saying 2025 this is a
demon saying 2025.
so the fullness of time as regards the
particular planning with which we are
dealing is from now until the year
2025. that's pretty definitive
a brief period of time indeed
in which to see the consummation of the
larger purpose of the planetary locus
that's the word
that is satan taking the place of jesus
christ
unbelievable
working through the three major centers
within his body of manifestation
that's his disciples
that's the governments of the world now
there are
rumors
in
the realms of let's say the king of mana
manna the king of manna
who rules all the nations and has this
pot of gold that he sits on to finance
the nations
that every single leader so they say in
these pages that every single leader
somehow has to sign a contract
with this logos
that's very interesting
we're deep into conspiracy theories now
but we're not
actually in conspiracy theories because
we're quoting directly from the sources
and if someone doesn't want to believe
these sources that's a prerogative
but the united nations runs its schedule
according to it
and the year 2025 is becoming
ubiquitous we're reading it here we're
reading it there
so
this purpose was threefold in nature
i've made this practical application and
this immediate illustration of teaching
a net glamour illusion and maya
because the whole world problem has
reached the crisis today
and because its clarification will be
the outstanding theme of all progress
now listen to this educational will we
be re-educated
is the pope having a meeting very soon
to tell us how to be re-educated yes do
they have re-education camps
do the jesuits in their articles tell us
that we need re-education yes
particularly starting with the youth yes
now what about this
difficult
elderly group would they perhaps have to
just be
eliminated to not rock the boat
religious re-education economic
re-education are we seeing that at the
moment
great reset
great reset and it must be done by when
and we have just started scratching at
the surface
where are we going
what is their plan
how to re-educate humanity
in terms of religious re-education
what is their plan in terms of the
economic reset
now
this all sounds like science fiction
we've talked about ufos we've talked
about contact with extraterrestrials
we've talked about hierarchy
we've talked about the logos the false
christ we've talked about planet x i
mean it is
ludicrous people will say now he's gone
totally insane
or has he
we'll see we'll see right
just to round it off let's just have a
look at the quote
from the spirit of prophecy
manuscripts release number 614 secret
societies and confederacies
as we near the close of time there will
be greater and still greater external
parade of heathen powers
what does that mean
that is interesting when you think of
all this that you've just mentioned in
the previous with all these what is an
external parade that's something that is
visible up
so as we near the close of time
there will be greater and still greater
external parade of heathen power
in other words the demonic forces will
manifest themselves
by when will this happen according to
allah say bailey by 2025 by 2025 all the
heathen power all the powers opposing
god
he heathen deities
will manifest their signal power
and will exhibit themselves before the
cities of the world and this delineation
has already begun to be fulfilled
when did spiritism start
in 1844. in
1844 there was the rapping
and the first communications started
taking place
from there on it has escalated into the
mighty new age movements
who's behind that movement whenever you
studied it
when you look at the total onslaught
series that i made you will find that
it's the jesuits
who are largely in control of all of
these movements
they have their agents in all of them
it is unbelievable so exactly what we
have been reading is predicted in the
spirit of prophecy our filter
correct
by a variety of images the lord jesus
represented to john the wicked character
and seductive influence
of those who have been distinguished for
their persecution of god's people who
are they
who has been distinguished for their
persecution of god's people
the roman catholic church absolutely
inquisition
how many millions of people were
destroyed by them so is rome going to be
involved in this yes rc christian
bringing about a
age of reason
depopulation
mind control
government control
reset economy reproduction control
reproduction control
religious control all need wisdom
carefully to search out the mystery of
iniquity that figures so largely in the
winding up of this earth's history now
my dear young brother
what did we pray for before we started
this discussion
for wisdom we prayed for wisdom
how many need wisdom to search this out
all
oh
is it therefore
pure conspiracy
theory to think about these things and
to ponder
how this fits into what is happening in
the world
or are we really onto something here
where we can
say it's here
people out there please wake up
wake up we're on the verge of the climax
of history
[Music]
we need to study these things this is
not a conspiracy it's not fear-mongering
it's a reality
wake up and
look what's going on
absolutely
this terrible picture drawn by john
where in revelation
to show how completely the powers of
earth will give themselves over to evil
powers of earth is that a universal
thing yes
should show those who have received the
truth how dangerous it is to link up
with secret societies
or to join themselves in any way with
those who do not keep the commandments
my brother
if people don't wake up now they will
never wake up
we have said nothing in this episode
we've just quote it we've just quoted
the
background
now
truth
is stranger than fiction
we have
opened
to view
the issues
and in the next episodes we will go to
it is absolutely
unbelievable what is happening in this
world today yes and my prayer is that
this will lead people to wake up and to
understand this great controversy
between good and evil we need to
understand where we are in this battle
and we need to make a choice
and if we can expose
this great evil
how
the powers of earth will give themselves
over to evil
if we can explain
that the system that is being set up is
evil to the call
then maybe people would rather choose
the living god yes and get hope
this is my aim this is our aim in this
project
wake up
choose the living god don't go along
with the system
[Music]
absolutely the lord is coming soon amen
the hierarchy
is telling them telling us what their
time frame is
don't listen to voices that tell you
that this is a long way off
it is at the door
may god give us wisdom
as we
discuss this further and see where the
world is heading and what the real core
of the decision is about it's really
about choosing between the character of
satan and the character of god let's
pray will you pray for us i will pray
our heavenly father
we live in such
interesting but also dangerous times and
we need your wisdom more than ever so we
ask that you bless us and help us with
discernment the holy spirit to help us
and also
that we can distinguish where we must go
from here but that we always know that
we have to put our full trust in you
thank you very all that you do for us in
jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe
click here
when the bell appears click again to get
notifications to watch the next video
click here
thank you